the price of things at two supermarkets
are different in different cities
toilet paper in duluth minnesota cost
3.99 a package while toilet paper in new
york city cost 8.95 a package
in duluth toothpaste costs 1.95 a tube
while in new york new york city it costs
5.25 cents a tube the data for this can
be encoded in the following grocery
matrix so let's see if this makes sense
so
they have the price of toilet paper in
duluth 399. that's this right over here
and then they have the price of toilet
paper in new york at 8.95 so that's this
right over here so this first row right
over here this is the toilet paper row
i'll just write tp for short toilet
that's the toilet paper row
and this first column looks like it's
duluth
while this second column looks like it's
new york city new
york city and let's see if that works
out for the other data in duluth toilet
paper costs a dollar ninety five a a
toothpaste costs a dollar ninety five a
tube so this
data right over here is right over here
so this looks like the toothpaste row
tooth
well toothpaste actually is also tp so
i'll just write out tooth
tooth so this is the toothpaste row this
is toothpaste in dilute the dollar
ninety-five toothpaste in new york city
525.
so that's how they have set up the data
right over here
which statements are true above the
which statements are true about the
above matrix select all that apply
the following matrix can also be used to
contain the same information as g and
that's what's interesting about a matrix
what we have right over here is a
essentially an encapsulation of all of
the data that we have in this upper
paragraph and it's useful because a
computer could make use of this data if
it's as long as it knows what these rows
and what these columns actually
represent
so the first thing they ask us
is whether the following matrix can also
be used to contain the same information
so let's see this is the price of toilet
paper in duluth
and this right over here is the price of
toilet paper in new york city
so they have the exact same first row so
i would say that looks like the toilet
paper row and that would be duluth
column and this would be the new york
city column
but then if we define things that way
then this would have to be the
toothpaste row
toothpaste
row but the price of toothpaste in
duluth is not 525 and the price of
toothpaste in new york city is not 195.
so this one is not representing the same
information as that up there they've
gotten they've
it's you know you can't just randomly
order these around now you could
represent it in other ways you could
have another
let's say i have the matrix a
we could have picked to do something
like this
where we could have said well maybe this
is the
maybe this is the toothpaste column
toothpaste column and maybe this is the
toilet paper column and that this first
row is new york city
and the second row is duluth you could
have done something like this toothpaste
in new york city was 5 25
toilet paper in new york city is 8.95
toothpaste in duluth is 195
and
toilet paper in duluth is 399.
so this would have been this this this
matrix a that i've just constructed this
does contain the same data because if we
appropriately define our columns and
rows to represent toothpaste or toilet
paper in new york city or duluth you can
contain that information the problem
with this one is it's not consistent
this first row makes us think okay this
must be the this must be the duluth
column this must be the new york city
column and that the second row must be
toothpaste since the first row is toilet
paper but then they got things mixed up
if they switch these two things around
then obviously you get the same matrix
but then at least the data would have
been consistent so i definitely would
not say that this matrix contains the
same information
the second column represents the price
of toothpaste in the two cities
so the second column is this right over
here no that's not the price of
toothpaste in the two cities that's the
price of the two different goods in new
york city so i wouldn't i wouldn't check
that one either
element g two comma one is equal to five
twenty five so when someone says so if
you have the matrix
and they give you two comma one these
are the indices of the row and the
column so this is says second row
first column
so let's go there second row so this is
1 2 second row
first column is right over there so g2
comma 1
is not
z2 comma 1 is not 5
is not 5
25. so i wouldn't check that one either
a change in the price of toilet paper in
duluth can be represented by the matrix
so toilet paper in duluth is
this entry of our matrix right over
there so a change in toilet paper in
duluth would represent a change in this
399. but they didn't change the 3.99
they changed the 9.75 the 975 would
represent a change in the price of
toilet paper in new york city so i
wouldn't check that one either so i
would only go
only go with none of the
none of the above